Okay, so I want to take up this as volume 15, and I want to take up in March 27, 1923.
And these are the sorrows of Jesus in the Blessed Sacrament.
Okay, Louisa said, "After I received Communion, my sweet Jesus made himself seen, and as soon
as I saw him, I threw myself at his feet to kiss them and to cling to him with all of
myself."
Now, that's Song of Songs 3-4, Song of Songs 3-4, and it's John 2017.
Song of Songs, it's the bride having refound her bridegroom.
She throws herself at his feet and clings to him.
And John 2017 is Mary of Magdalene on Easter Day.
Jesus said, "My daughter, coming to my arms and even inside my heart, I have covered myself
with the eucharistic veils so as not to strike fear.
I have descended into the deepest abyss of humiliations in this sacrament.
I mean, who would want to present themselves as a piece of bread?
In order to raise the creature up to me, identifying her with me so much as to form one single
thing with me.
And by letting my sacramental blood flow inside of her veins, I would constitute myself the
source of the life of her heartbeat, of her thought, and of her whole being.
My love devoured me and wanted to devour the creature in my flames to make her be reborn
as another me.
So the reborn, the new creature in Christ is 2 Corinthians 5-17, 2 Corinthians 5-17.
This is why I wanted to hide myself under these eucharistic veils and so hidden enter
into her to form this transformation of the creature into myself."
Well, that's the teaching of John chapter 6, that receiving Jesus in the Eucharist is
transformative to the point where he raises up on the last day.
And notice he hides himself in the Eucharist in order to enable us not to be afraid of
him and to receive him with ease.
But in order for this transformation to take place, the dispositions were needed on the
part of all souls.
And my love, giving in to excess in instituting the sacrament of the Eucharist, released from
within my divinity, more graces, gifts, favors, and light for the good of man.
To render him worthy to receive me.
So notice all the helps to make us worthy for him is all done by him.
I could say that it really so much good as to surpass the gifts of creation, which is
amazing.
First, I wanted to give him, that's the humanity, the graces in order for him to receive me and
then myself to give him the true fruit of the sacramental life.
So Jesus has won all the grace, all the merits, and he gives everything, this is pure gift.
Okay.
So in the next paragraph, he talks about the dispositions that we actually need to be able
to benefit from this.
However, in order to anticipate souls with these gifts, it takes a little emptying of
themselves.
That's number one.
Number two, my book says, "Hate of sin," hatred of sin is English.
Number two is hatred of sin.
And number three, an actual desire to receive me.
Now notice receiving communion habitually or just because you happen to be in the church
is not it.
So we have to have three dispositions, a little emptying of themselves.
Now notice, he's not asking for much.
Hatred of sin and a desire to receive him.
These gifts do not descend into rot and mud.
This is terribly important, okay.
So I need to give you Habakkuk 113, Lord your eyes are too holy to look upon evil.
And also Hebrews 12, 14, nothing unholy or unworthy can enter the presence of God.
So you also need one Corinthians 11, where Paul teaches on the Eucharist.
And in verse 29, he says that if we receive the Eucharist without recognizing the body,
in other words with the disdain that we're eating and drinking to our own condemnation.
That's one Corinthians 11, 29, okay.
So therefore without these gifts, they do not have the true dispositions to receive
me.
Now this is volume 15, and in volumes 1 to 7, particularly, we have Louisa asking the
Lord many times to dispose her to receive him.
And she says, you prepare me, otherwise who can be worthy of you.
So without these gifts, they don't have the true dispositions to receive me.
And descending into them, I do not find the space to communicate my life.
Now I want you to ring the word space.
You know that if a room is cluttered, you can't put any more furniture in.
It's actually that simple.
And if you go to radiantlight.org, you know, I've mentioned it many times, Elizabeth Wang.
One of the images that I find very amazing is that she has drawn an image of a soul receiving
communion.
Now if I asked you to draw that, I'd love to know what you would draw.
I would expect you to draw the person on the outside with their hands out or their tongue
out to receive.
She didn't do that.
She drew a soul like a womb that must contain somebody, okay.
And she had Jesus sitting on the edge of the soul, looking down into it with a puzzled
look on his face, because there was no room for him.
Now this was a good person receiving Holy Communion.
And inside she had all kinds of boxes, tall and small and round ones and square ones and
all kinds of things.
But the place was cluttered completely.
And the boxes indicated not big sins, but stuff that flutters you.
And so there was really no room for him.
And this is why he said, "I don't find the space to communicate my life.
I am as though dead for them."
Well when you see the behavior of some people after communion, you understand that.
And they are dead for me, in other words, there's no communication.
And there's no relationship.
I burn, that's the divine love, okay, but they don't feel my flames.
Now the opposite of that is that St. Therese of Liz Yu said that every single time she
received Holy Communion, she was aware of growing in holiness.
Now I find that a very disturbing statement, because I haven't found anybody else who said
that.
It might be Louisa, but the rest of us.
And he said, "I burn, but they don't feel my flames.
I am light and they remain more blinded because they're acting out of darkness."
So for that, I am light and they remain more blinded.
I want to give you John 9, 40 to 41, John 9, 40 to 41.
That's the Pharisees standing before Jesus, who is the light of the world.
And he had just removed permanent blindness from a man who had no eye sockets.
And Jesus actually created eyes for him and gave him sight.
And yet they were completely blind to who Jesus was.
Jesus says, "Alas, how many sorrows in my sacramental life?
Many feeling nothing good in receiving me because it needs to add of their lack of dispositions."
My book says simply because of lack of dispositions, it's theirs, the problems on our side.
They reached the point of nauseating me, Jesus said.
And even if they continue to receive me, it is to form my continuous Calvary and their
eternal damnation.
That is Jesus underlining the teaching of 1 Corinthians 11.
Because that's what Paul says, that if we receive him unworthily, that we're eating
and drinking to our own condemnation.
So it's really better for people not to go to communion if they're not right with God.
It's actually better.
They're not adding to their problems on the other side.
So, if it is not love that pushes them to receive me, now notice the big "if" clause.
If it's not love that pushes them to receive me, it's one more affront that they give me
one more sin that they add to their souls.
Now you know from volumes 1 to 6 that Jesus keeps underlining all the time, all the time
there's only one motive I accept from you and that you do everything for love of me.
So to actually go and receive him, and it's not for love of him, it doesn't make sense
at all, does it?
So notice that you can go to Mass and communion and come out more sinful than you went in.
Isn't that scary?
They add one more sin to their souls, therefore pray and repair for the many abuses and sacrileges
that are committed in receiving me in the sacrament.
That's it.
You need to put a government health warning sign on it.
That's a major warning, okay, so I'm just going to write major warning on it.
Would you see Jesus actually affirming the teaching of St. Paul there?
And we have another very, very important message in April the 2nd, 1923, and it's about the
divine will itself.
The divine will is the seed of resurrection to grace.
This is very important, we've had some messages on this before.
But to summarize what I've just said, that the divine will is the seed of resurrection
to grace, it means every act we do in the divine will is another step towards our spiritual
resurrection, every single act we do, which is absolutely fantastic, okay?
So it's the seed of resurrection to grace, to sanctity and to glory.
Now as I was in my usual state, Louisa said, my beloved Jesus made himself seen all lovable
and majestic, as though unwrapped in a net of light.
He sent forth light from his eyes, I'm turning this into English, is that okay?
He unleashed light from his mouth and also at each word, at each heartbeat and each movement
and step of his.
Is that all right?
Turn that into English prayer.
So God is light, one John, one five, so naturally it's light that goes forth from him.
Now you know long before you came to volume 15 that the divine will is light and that
all the manifestations of the divine will to Louisa are all lights and she actually says
I received a light.
We call that enlightenment or infused knowledge, but it's light.
It's God revealing you to you.
And so she says in some his humanity was an abyss of light, okay?
Now remember Mount Tabar when he was transformed into light, okay?
Luke 9 29, he's transformed into light and I also want to give you Sam 104 verse 2, Lord
you are wrapped in a robe of light.
So it was on Mount Tabar that Jesus revealed to Peter and James and John what he was going
to be like in the resurrection.
And when he came back to them in the resurrection, he had to diminish the light to make himself
tolerable to them, okay?
So he is an abyss of light and Jesus looking at me, bound me with this light, telling me
my daughter how much light, how much glory did my humanity have in my resurrection?
Because the because is very important.
During the course of my life on this earth, I did nothing but enclose the supreme will
in each one of my acts, breaths and gazes in everything.
And as I kept enclosing it, the divine volition prepared for me glory and light in the resurrection.
And since I contain the immense sea of the light of my will within me, it is no wonder
if as I look, I speak, I move so much light comes out of me as to be able to give light
to all.
Okay, so before I go on, I want to give you 1 Timothy 6, 1 Timothy 6 verses 15 to 16.
Paul is talking about the appearing, that means the coming back of our Lord Jesus Christ.
And he says, "At due time he will be revealed by God, the blessed and holy ruler of all.
He will be revealed as the king of kings and the Lord of lords, who alone is immortal,
whose home is in inaccessible light, whom no man has seen and no man is able to see to
him be glory and everlasting power forever."
Jesus is in that inaccessible light, which is the blessed trinity, okay?
And as we go on in these writings, we're going to hear the divine will spoken of as
the unity of the light, okay?
When Jesus wants to show Louisa just how high a blessed mother is in heaven, he's going
to take her into heaven and she can see the angels and the saints and she says, "I can't
see the celestial mother at all," and Jesus smiles.
And she says, "She had to be taken very deep into this abyss of light before she could
even perceive blessed mother, because she was deepest."
And so she speaks about the height of Mary, and it means the summit of holiness.
So this stuff is very deep, this particular one, okay?
So Jesus is in that inaccessible light.
He is that light himself, okay?
And so whenever he appears, the first thing you see is light, and then he comes out of
the light and shows himself.
And he says, "Therefore, I want to chain you," that's Louisa, "and overwhelm you in
this light in order to sow in you as many seeds of resurrection, whereas many acts as you
keep doing in my will."
So every act is a seed of resurrection.
Make sure you take that out and rise it up somewhere so that you keep doing the act.
Every act is a seed of resurrection.
My will alone makes the soul and body rise again to glory.
I'll talk to you on the 29th about the rising of the body to glory, okay?
My will alone makes the soul and the body rise again to glory.
Now as we go on in the higher volumes, Louisa is more and more and more spiritualized because
each seed, each act is a seed of resurrection.
What you saw on Mount Tabor was that Jesus was spiritualized, okay?
What happens in the assumption is that Mary's body is spiritualized, okay?
So she lived in the divine will, and every act that we do is a movement in that direction
as well, okay?
I saw somebody recently who's in the divine will and the thing that struck me, I never
said a word to the person, the thing that struck me, I'm going to say she, but I'm not indicating
whether it was a she or a he or an it, what really struck me was that the person looked
luminous.
I've talked to one of us, and that person was not aware of what was being communicated
to me because we were talking about something perfectly ordinary, but there was a luminous
thing coming from this person, okay?
So my will makes the soul and the body rise again to glory.
My will is the seed of resurrection to grace, and you need to add and the seed of resurrection
to the highest and perfect sanctity.
So it is the seed of resurrection to grace and the seed of resurrection to the highest
and perfect sanctity, and you need to also add and the seed of resurrection to glory.
He's underlying it at each point.
First of all, it's the seed of resurrection to grace, then to the highest and most perfect
sanctity, and then to glory, okay?
So in other words, a three-step process.
Do you remember I said to you already, or maybe I didn't, I said it to some group, that
in Matthew 3, 11, Matthew speaks about you will be baptized in the Holy Spirit and fire.
Did I tell you that one?
Matthew 3, 11, and then that's Matthew 3, 10, and the following verse, verse 11, he says,
and if you don't cooperate with that, you'll be thrown on the fire that never goes out.
Okay, so the baptism of the Holy Spirit and fire, let me tell you what that is.
There's a four-step process that goes on.
The Holy Spirit cleanses, that's the big dart if I can put it that way, purifies, that's
going to the roots of the problems.
So the stage one is cleansing.
So an even in divine will, if we're not being cleansed and purified, there's something radically
wrong.
The first stage is the cleansing.
The second stage is the purifying.
You pull up the weeds by the roots or you'll be back pulling them again.
And the third stage is sanctifying and the fourth stage is glorifying, okay?
Cleansing, purifying, sanctifying and glorifying, they're the four stages.
And if you resist that, then you're sort of a failed product if I can put it that way,
and you have to go on to the inert fire that will never cleanse, never purify, never sanctify
and never glorify forever.
So if you go to hell angry, you get worse and worse and worse and worse.
Whereas if you go to heaven loving, you get better and better and better and better.
It is growth all the time.
So you see that Jesus gives you three stages here, the resurrection to grace, then the resurrection
to the highest and perfect sanctity because the divine will is the highest sanctity.
And then finally the resurrection to glory.
So as the soul emits her acts in my will, she keeps binding new divine light and my will
is light by nature because God is light.
And one who lives in it has the power, the word virtue is used as power there.
It has the power of transforming thoughts, words, works, everything she does into light.
In other words, into a spiritual substance.
So we start off with a muddy substance, a heavy substance.
And by the time he's finished, you're a spiritual substance.
Now your soul and your spirit are already spiritual, but the body has to get all of this as well.
So divine acts are the seeds of resurrection to glory.
The divine will is the seed of resurrection to grace, the seed of the highest perfection
and sanctity and the seed of resurrection to glory.
The divine will is light, God is light and everything must be transformed to light because
God is light and that's what heaven is.
So I want to give you for that end piece, John 3 19 to 21.
Some people reject the light and choose the darkness.
And that's the thing that corresponds with Matthew 3 10 to 11.
Some people just reject the purification process and they are by that very fact choosing darkness.
Okay, so then afterwards, Louisa said, I was saying to my sweet Jesus, I pray in your will.
So that my word multiplying in the divine will may have a word of prayer, praise, blessing,
love, reparation for each word of each person.
I would want my voice to rise between heaven and earth and absorb all human voices into
itself in order to give them back to you as homage and glory according to the way you
would want the creature to make use of his word.
So there's this wonderful prayer in the divine will which you'll find in that little prayer
book.
Now as I was saying this, my beloved Jesus placed his mouth close to mine and blowing
with his breath, he absorbed my breath, now you won't get it, you won't absorb somebody
else's breath by blowing.
So they should be saying inhaling, inhaling or breathing in, okay.
With his breath, he absorbed my breath, my voice, my breathing into his.
So that's an inhalation and as he, as he put it as though on the way in his will, it went
through each human word and changed words and voices according to what I had said.
So in the first sentence, you have Louisa's prayer and now you have Jesus' response.
He's telling her that what she has asked in the divine will has actually happened.
It happens instantly.
And it's good to say prayer and response because that's, I give a commentary on my own book
to myself, I just have prayer and response there.
So Louisa remained amazed or she said, and as it went through the people, it rose high
in order to do the office of all human voices before God in the name of all.
So Louisa was amazed and remembering that Jesus no longer spoke to her so often about
his will, she said, "Tell me, my love, why do you no longer speak to me so often about
your will?
And he, and he doing his best."
They were in the middle of a huge teaching about the will and she's telling him, he doesn't
do it.
"Is it perhaps because I've not been attentive to your lessons and faith will put in your
teachings into practice?"
Okay.
So in the next paragraph, he's going to show her how to bring the divine will down to earth
and start the new era, how to bring it down from heaven to the earth because that's her
job, isn't it?
So Jesus said, "My daughter, in my will, there is a void of the human works in the divine
and this void must be filled by one who lives in my will.
The more attentive you are in living in my will and in making it known to others."
Now, underline that one three times and in making it known to others.
The sooner this void will be filled because none of us individually, not even Luisa, could
fill it all.
You're only one.
So you have to multiply the number of people who will do the acts in the divine will.
So we have to be telling other people about it.
The sooner the void will be filled and that void has to be filled for the new Jerusalem
to become a reality, you see, in such a way that as my will sees the human will hovering
around within itself, as though returning to the origin from which it came, it will feel
satisfied and will see its yearnings upon the human generations being fulfilled.
There should be an S on that human generations because it's everybody past, present and future.
It doesn't matter whether they are few, they are the people doing the acts in the divine
will.
It doesn't matter if they are few and maybe even one, we would say just one, we don't
say one alone.
That's not English, okay, because with the power of the divine will, my will can make
up for everything even for one alone when it doesn't find others.
At the moment, that fits Louisa, you know, but it is always a human will that must come
into mind to substitute for everything that the others don't do, so there we have it.
He needs us to stop complaining and start substituting.
Stop giving out about what's wrong and getting on with repairing, okay.
Each additional entrance that you make into my will, that's every time you fuse and do
an act, pushes me to give you more knowledge about it.
You can't say knowledge is in English.
It's already a plural word.
And to narrate to you more projities, which has to have an S because it's not a plural
word because I want you to know the good you do so that you may appreciate it and desire
to possess it.
Now Hosea 4.6 says that without knowledge, the people perish.
Without knowledge, the people perish.
If we don't pass on this knowledge to other people in Ireland, there's a lot of people
who could do wonders in the divine will who won't simply because we didn't tell them.
Okay.
So Hosea 4.6 without knowledge, the people perish.
Now Jesus is going to say something about knowledge from the other angle.
Hosea said, "What happens without the knowledge?"
Jesus says here.
And in seeing that you love this knowledge and appreciate it, I give you possession of
it.
This is the VIP statement, "Knowledge is the eyes of the soul."
In other words, it enables you to understand what God is saying and who he is in so far
as a creature can.
The soul does not know, who does not know is as though blind to that good and to those
truths.
Now all the people who haven't yet heard of divine will are blind to it all.
They have no idea what they're missing.
In my will, there are no blind souls.
That also is a VIP statement.
Rather, each knowledge brings her a greater length of sight.
Now look at the word lengths.
You're talking about distance.
Isaiah is called a seer, as distinct from a prophet, he's a prophet as well, because
he was able to see 800 years into the future.
We're starting Daniel and he's able to see right to the end of history.
That's distance sight, okay?
So that's what he means by lengths of sight.
"Therefore, enter often into my volition, expand your boundaries in my will.
And as I see this, I will come back and tell you more surprising things about my will.
Now I want you to put light sight.
When you open up to the light, you get the sight.
When you get the sight, you'll move towards the light, so it's light sight.
And that's Sam 36 verses 8 to 9.
Light sight.
So the next paragraph is about the sword of sorrow.
And now while he was saying this, together we went around the earth for a little while.
Oh, that's your Amos 3, 7 again.
And Isaiah 64, 10, as he's going to tell her about the future.
We went around here.
Oh, what fright she said.
Many wanted to wound my beloved Jesus, some by knife, some by sword.
And among them, there were bishops, priests and religious.
Okay.
Now, you know the source of that, don't you?
It's the communist infiltration and the infiltration of the Freemasons.
And it's 1923.
You already have modernism.
You have liberalism.
And it was all condemned by Pope Pius the 10th in his syllabus of errors.
And he died in 1914.
So little pieces of information like that actually help you to understand.
And of course, what we're reading here is much more real for us now because we're reaping
the terrible fruits of that particular time.
So among them were bishops, priests and religious who wounded him deep into his heart, but with
such torture as to strike fright.
Why would that be?
It's because their position is such that they can destroy the word of God.
They can destroy the theology and they can destroy the liturgy, which they've done a
pretty good job at trying to do.
Okay.
That's the destruction of the church from within that the communist said was necessary
if the church was to die.
So how Jesus suffered and threw himself into my arms to be defended, I pressed him to myself
and prayed him to let me share his pains.
He made me content by piercing my heart through with such vehemence that I felt a deep wound
within me the whole day and he came back many times to help.
So let me give you the same thing in different language.
Jesus shows her the passion of the church going towards its crucifixion and the crucifixion
is still coming for us in the West.
They've had their crucifixion in the Soviet Union.
Okay.
They've had their crucifixion in the Middle East was still coming to us.
We are still given time.
So Louisa is given the sword of sorrow to help to make reparation for this.
You know that at the foot of the cross, blessed mother was given the sword of sorrow in her
cooperation with redemption as well.
So Louisa says the following morning as I was feeling strong pain, I would imagine since
he drove this thing into her heart with such vehemence to say she has strong pain is saying
it very mildly, okay.
Jesus came back saying to me, let me see your heart because he has wounded it, hasn't he?
And while he was looking he told me, do you want me to heal you in order to relieve you
from the pain you are suffering?
Well, of course all the rest of us would say yes.
And Louisa said my highest good, why do you want to heal me?
Am I not worthy of suffering for you?
There is an attitude to suffering that we should at least allow to challenge us.
Your heart is all wounded and mine compared to yours or how scarce is my suffering rather
if it pleases you give me more pains.
I don't know if you put an exclamation mark there, I do.
But he's squeezing me all over, continued to pierce my heart through with more pain and
then he left me.
In other words, he is so pleased to have somebody who will stand at the foot of the cross for
the church as his mother stood at the foot of the cross for him, okay.
So April the 9th, 1923, God is the prime motion of all creation, theology says it just in
different words, he's the prime mover, okay.
So Louisa said, I felt all immersed in the divine volition.
And I said to my sweet Jesus, ah, I pray you, never let me go out of your most holy will.
Now there's a very good prayer for you and me.
Would it be so that I may always think, speak, work and love in your divine will?
And as I was saying this, she said, I felt myself surrounded by a most pure light.
Now that's the divine will.
And I saw my highest and only good who told me, my beloved daughter, I love these acts
done in my will so much, the so much is in the wrong place, okay.
That as soon as the soul enters into the divine will in order to act, the shadow of
my light surrounds her.
We're so tiny, small and puny that we can only tolerate the shadow, okay.
We have to understand how small we are.
He told Louisa she was only an atom, okay.
And he said, and I run so that my act and hers may be one.
You get that in Tony's little book, you desire it, I do it, okay.
Because I am the prime act of all creation or the prime mover.
Without my prime motion, all created things will be paralyzed without strength and incapable
of the slightest movement.
Now in higher volumes he's going to tell us that life is in the movement.
And it's fascinating to watch an infant and very small children and they never stop,
do they?
Every part of the body is moving.
And that's the body actually developing itself.
But I'm always fascinated by it, I say, yeah, the life is in the motion.
It's fascinating.
And sometimes even when they're, as we would say, dead asleep, they're still thrashing
around, it's fascinating to see it, the extraordinary life they have.
So life is in the motion and notion that everything in creation moves, the stars move,
the planets move, everything moves.
Without it, everything is dead.
I am the prime mover, okay, it says motion in the book.
And I give life and attitude to all other emotions.
I think that's a dispositions to move, isn't it?
So at my first motion, creation begins to rotate.
It happens as to an engine, think of a Swiss watch, and it's going to give you this in
greater detail as we go on.
And the only example I can think of the Swiss watch, that you have one thing turning and
all the others are etched into that.
And as it turns, all the others turn as well, that's what he's going to talk about.
It happens as to an engine, at the touch of the first motion of the first wheel, the
other wheels begin to rotate.
See then, it is almost natural for one who operates in my will to move in my prime motion.
Because we go into the divine will, we're going to the inside of things and moving things
from within, that's where the divine will is operating, okay.
And by operating in my motion, she finds herself and operates in the motion of all creatures.
So if we enter into the divine, Jesus, we're entering the intellect of everyone, okay.
We enter into his heart, we're entering into the hearts of everyone.
So we're right in there where the divine will is operating as the prime mover.
And as the creature flows in my own motion, I see her and I feel in her all the motions
of creatures giving me as many divine acts for as many offensive human acts others do.
So it's in there, we cancel out evil and we substitute and repair.
We fill in the good, you cancel out evil, fill in the voids, you're substituting and
you're repairing, you're doing something at the very, very heart of a person's life.
That's like saying that a neurosurgeon has the job of knitting you together inside, then
he just puts the skin back.
But the thing he's doing is putting the vital nerves together.
And so I remember hearing some people in the North of Ireland talking about at the time
of the troubles, there were so many people injured that the neurosurgeons became the
prime doctors because they were the ones on call.
And because they had so many limbs to try and seek what they put back, they became first
class.
They had more experience than most doctors, you know, even doctors of their own areas,
you know, and in other countries neurosurgeons began to ask them to teach them what they
had learned.
So we become very efficient at enabling the Lord to recreate the human race, okay?
So beside that, therefore, put Jeremiah 29/11, creating a future full of hope because it's
enabling the human race to actually heal from within.
And this only because she has operated in my prime motion.
This is why I say that one who lives in my will substitutes for everybody and defends
me from all, that's defending him from the evil and places my motion, my very life in
safety.
Would you ever, this last piece here should be colored if you have a color.
And right in your margin, this is his triumph, this is the triumph of the Sacred Heart.
So let me read it again.
This is why, this is why I say that one who lives in my will substitute for all defends
me from all and places my motion and my very life and safety.
And this is why to operate in my will is the Prodigy of Progesis and without clamor, without
human acclimations, it is my true triumph over the whole of creation.
And since it is a triumph which is fully divine, what is human remains silent and has no equivalent
words with which to acclaim the triumph of the Supreme Will and they're absolutely fantastic.
Now you know what the triumph looks like and you realize you're part of it, it's not fantastic.
But you see, if we do our act more conscious of what we're doing, they will be more profound.
They will be deeper.
Is that okay?
And that's why I think that these teachings are absolutely superb.
So April the 14th, 1923, anything we do for God has got to be for everybody because he's
for everybody.
And if you limit things to one person or a few people, then you haven't got the vision
of the divine will.
So Louisa said, I was thinking about how my beloved Jesus keeps manifesting to me about
his most holy will.
And many doubts and difficulties arise within my mind, which I don't believe it's necessary
to say here, now I have a hunch that these doubts and difficulties are the reactions
of the priest saying that from theology you can say this and from theology you can say
that and you can't say this and you can't say the other because Louisa is too simple
a person to concoct all these problems, but the priest stimulating her like this is actually
very important for us because she gets answers that we need, because these are questions
that we would come up with.
Then moving in my interior and clasping me tightly to his heart, he told me, I love this
clasping me tightly to his heart.
I don't know if this means anything to you, but when I was very young my dad had a thing
that he called a hard love and that is he would take you and he would hold you very,
very tightly and he would only do that if he wanted to get something through to you.
And one of the reasons why I got into scripture is that he and I used to go for long walks
and he'd walk the legs off me and I'd say to him, listen you'll have to carry me back
and every time we were always talking about scripture and talking about God and everything
and every time he wanted to get something through he either pulled me from the shoulder
close to him as we were walking along or he would squeeze my hand so tightly I think
I was going to break all the bones and he was hardly aware of it, he was hardly aware
of it.
It was just that he was meditating all the time and he was talking to me and then I
might ask him a question and he'd go on for another half hour and then he'd squeeze
the hand for every single thing he wanted you to really receive and I called the hard
love, sorry he called it the hard love and it comes back to me every time I read this
tasking me tightly to his heart and then he tells her something special.
In other words I really want you to get this one, okay.
So he said, beloved daughter of my will, you must know that when I want to do great works
as distinct from works because he's doing works all the time.
Works in which the whole human family is to take part, that's creation, redemption and
sanctification, the three fiends, always if it wants it of course because human beings
have free will, my usual way is to centralize all the goods and all the graces which this
work contains in one single creature, so that all others may draw as much as they want from
that good as though as from a found, that's like saying he sets up a bank in one person
and all the others can draw from the bank.
When I do individual works he said, I give limited things, but when I do works which
must serve for the good of all I give things without limit, so for that I want to give
you Ephesians chapter 1 verses 1 to 14, Ephesians 1, 1 to 14.
So in the next paragraph we're going to have the first example, redemption and in the second
long paragraph we're going to have the new era of the divine will.
So Jesus said, I did this in the work of redemption, this is the first example he's
giving to her.
In order to be able to elevate a creature to conceiving a man and God, I had to centralize
all possible imaginable goods in her.
I had to elevate her so high as to placing her the seed of every paternal fecundity,
it's not amazing.
So that as my celestial father, Virgin, is that interesting, generated me within his
womb with the virginal seed of his eternal fecundity.
I mean this requires you to take all the words separately and write them down and stay with
that particular word until you get it.
This eternal fecundity is Sam 2, 7.
Sam 1, 2, 7.
Sorry not 1, 2, 7.
Sam 2, verse 7, the eternal fecundity of God, he created in the eternal time.
It was without the work of a woman, that's why he's calling the celestial father Virgin.
And from the same seed the Holy Spirit proceeded, so the son and the Holy Spirit came from the
father without any intervention of anybody else.
He's just using our language and calling him a virgin, I've never heard God the Father
talked about as a virgin before, have you?
In the same way with this eternal seed of the paternal fecundity, Holy Virgin, in other
words nobody else is involved.
My celestial mother conceived me in her virginal womb without the work of a man.
Now look at the seed came from a man without the work of a woman, where would the work
of a woman come into that?
Just think of it for a minute now, he's saying that the seed that produced Jesus from God
the Father was without the work of a woman, what would be the work of a woman in producing
the seed of man, that she is the mother of the man, okay, that she's the mother of the
man, that's where her involvement would be.
So the father produces the eternal seed without the help of anybody else, he's the only one
in eternity.
And then his mother conceived without the work of a man, I want to give you two Peter
one, 17 to 18, two Peter one, 17 to 18.
The most holy trinity had to give of its own to this divine virgin, so that she might
conceive me the son of God, so he is eternally begotten son of the Father, and then begotten
of Mary in time.
My holy mother could never have conceived me without having a seed, naturally, because
every woman must have a seed, okay.
Now since she belonged to the human race, this seed of eternal fecundity gave her the
power of conceiving me as man.
And because the seed was divine, at the same time she conceived me as God, now there you
have the theological answer for anybody as to why she used to be called the mother of
God, because all our Protestant brethren have problems with this.
And just as the Holy Spirit proceeded at the same time as the Father generated me, that
is in the eternal time, in the same way I was generated in the womb of my, as I was
generated, I keep on forgetting the little word as there.
As I was generated in the womb of my mother, the generation of souls proceeded at the same
time.
Isn't that something else?
We can talk about this later.
So everything that ab a eternal from eternity occurred to the most holy Trinity in heaven
was repeated in the womb of my dear mother.
The work was immense and incalcable to the created mind.
I had to centralize all goods and even myself in her understood so that all might find whatever
they wanted.
If God hadn't given her all of this, she wouldn't have been a bank for us.
If Jesus doesn't give all this material that he's giving to Louisa on divine will, she
doesn't become a bank for us either.
If we don't fill ourselves up with divine will and divine acts, we can't become a bank
from anybody else either because you can only give what you have.
So this is why, since the work of redemption was to be so great as to overwhelm all generations,
that's from the first to the last, I wanted for many centuries, this is important, the
prayers, the size, the tears and the penances of so many patriarchs and prophets and of the
whole people of the Old Testament.
Now we put this into the introduction, you see, and that is approximately 2,000 years
of prayers, size, tears and penances.
In other words, he needed a bank of prayer and desire and intercession coming from the
earth.
He needed these from the whole people of the Old Testament, every one of them.
And I did this in order to dispose them to receive a good, so great and to move me to
centralize this, in this celestial creature, all the goods that everyone was to enjoy.
So in other words, for the whole time of the Old Testament, the people are asking the
Messiah to come, Lord send us the Savior, okay.
And you get all these marvelous prayers in the Psalms, send forth your light and your
truth, let these be my guide.
That's exactly what he does in the redemption and in the divine will.
So they have to keep asking for this.
So what moved this people to pray and to sigh was the promise of the future Messiah.
What was the promise given? It's in Genesis 3, 15.
In other words, it was given before the chosen people were ever born, before they ever became
a people.
It was given in Genesis 3, 15.
It was given at the time of the fall.
The promise was like the seed of so many supplications and tears.
And notice that seed is being used as source.
It was the source of so many, or the cause, okay, of so many supplications and tears.
Had there not been this promise, no one would have given it a thought, no one would have
hoped for salvation.
So notice there's the seed of God's Word sown in the earth and it must grow and grow and
flourish and at the right time, everything will be fulfilled.
Wonderful stuff, isn't it?
Now once he has laid down the plan, he's going to say this a number of times in different
ways as we go on.
Once the plan is laid down, then he says, "Now, Louise, you understand what I'm doing
with you because I'm doing the same thing on a different level."
So the next paragraph is the new era of divine will, okay?
Now my daughter, let's come to my will.
So between the last paragraph and this one is 2,000 years.
And that's right, you've got the 2,000 years of Christianity.
Do you think it's a sanctity like the other sanctities, a good, a grace almost like the
others, which I had given for so many centuries to the other saints in the whole church?
Oh, no, this is about a new era.
This is a complete break.
It's not a break in the sense that there's nothing going before it, but it's just not
a follow up, okay?
So the sanctity and the divine will is completely different to sanctities that go before it.
Hence, you have to already have the sanctity going before it before you can go on into
this.
You can't be a beginner.
This is a new era.
This is about a good that must serve all generations, see, that's what he said.
If I do something that's to serve all generations, I centralize it in one person.
But it's necessary that I first centralize this good in one creature, just as I did in
redemption by centralizing everything in my mother.
Take a look at how things proceed in a parallel way.
In order to make redemption come and to dispose souls for it, I made the promise of the future
of Messiah, so that by hoping for him to come, they would not only dispose themselves but
find that they also, their own salvation in the future redeemer, okay?
That sentence is VIP.
Their hope in the coming of the redeemer and their praying for the redeemer was their
participation because his redemption was going to be past, present, and future, okay?
So they were saved also through Christ.
So I want to give you there not a direct quotation but an interesting one.
If you just put CF to look up, 1 Peter 3.18.
Now 1 Peter 3.18 tells you that when Jesus died, he went down into limbo to tell all
the souls that were waiting and to give them the final instructions that the Messiah had
come and they were the very first ones to accept them fully, okay?
Now in order to dispose souls to live in my will, to let them partake in the goods it
contains and to make man return to the path of his origin, just as he was created by me,
I myself wanted to pray the first, as the first, making my voice resound from one end
of the earth to the other and even up high in heaven, saying our Father who art in heaven.
Now when he says he makes his voice heard throughout the earth, his voice is heard through
all Christians throughout the earth.
I did not say my Father, okay?
Avi is my Father, Avinu is our Father, A-V-I-N-U is Avinu and it doesn't sound wonderful
on my lips but when I heard Jewish man praying Avinu, it was just totally different, it came
out of the depths of his being.
So Avi, A-V-I, is my Father, okay?
Now usually when that is written in English, in phonetics it's A-B-I-N-A-B-I-N-U but I'm
giving you the correct pronunciation which is A-V, okay, so that's why I said Avinu.
So I said Avinu, I did not say Avi but I called him Father of the whole human family.
So as to engage him in that which I was going to do may all that every nation under heaven
hallow at your name so that your kingdom may come and your will be done on earth as it
is in heaven.
This was the purpose of creation and I asked the Father that it would be fulfilled.
As I prayed the Father surrendered to my supplications and I formed the seed, the origin,
the source of a good that was so great.
We would say this great good in English.
And so that this seed might be known, I taught my prayer to the apostles and they transmitted
it to the whole church.
Now notice it had to be known if it wasn't known, it wasn't going to be appreciated.
So that just as the people of the future Redeemer found salvation in him and disposed itself
to receive the promised Messiah in the same way with this seed that's the Our Father.
And by me the church might pray and repeat my very prayer many times and might dispose
herself to receive the good of recognizing and loving the celestial Father as their Father.
In such a way as to deserve to be loved as children, not as servants or outsiders and
receive the great good that my will be done on earth as it is in heaven.
So in this seed, so you know that this particular seed is the Our Father and in this hope because
that's what it is, the hope for the divine will to come on earth, that my will be done
on earth as it is in heaven, the very saints have formed their sanctity, the martyrs have
shed their blood.
There is no good which does not derive from this seed.
So the whole church prays and just as the tears, penances and prayers to obtain the
Messiah were directed towards the excelling virgin, that's blessed mother, whom I was
to dispose in order to centralize such a great good in her so that they might receive their
Savior even though they did not know who she would be in the same way now, this is 21st
century, 20th century for Louisa, when the church recites the Our Father, it is precisely
for you.
That's incredible that the Our Father is directed towards Louisa who will open the door.
It's not absolutely incredible so the only commentary I have on the side is well, okay.
So it is precisely for you that she prays so that I may centralize in you all the good
that my will contains the way and the how and so on.
The divine will may have life on earth as it does in heaven and even though you are not
known by echoing my prayer, thy will be done on earth as it is in heaven, the church is
praying to me and it presses me to centralize all this good in a second virgin so that like
a second Savior she may save on safe humanity.
And making use of my inseparable love and mercy, I may answer my own prayer, isn't that
very interesting?
So the church is the body of Christ continuing to pray as Christ on the earth and asking
the Father to centralize everything in Louisa so that the prayer can be answered.
It's fascinating.
So I may answer my own prayer, united to that of the whole church, making man come back
to his origin to the purpose for which I created him, that my will be done on earth as it is
in heaven.
This is precisely the living in my will.
So doing God's will on earth as in heaven is living in the divine will.
And everything I keep manifesting to you pushes you to this, confirms you in this.
This is the great foundation of the new era understood.
This is the great foundation I keep forming in your soul.
And in order to do this, I keep centralizing in you all the graces past, present and future,
which I've given to all generations, not just to Christian generations.
Even more, I double them.
I multiply them because since my will is the greatest, the holiest and the most noble thing,
it has no beginning and no end in order to place it in one person.
It's right and proper that I centralize in her all possible goods, innumerable graces,
divine purity.
Look at that.
Matthew five, eight, only the pure and heart see God, divine purity and nobility.
Now listening to Louisa, you wouldn't think there was any nobility, would you?
I'm always so bad, she says.
So that this will of mine may have the same courtage that it has in heaven.
Now notice he has to have the same conditions on earth as in heaven, otherwise he can't
tolerate it.
It's the same will that operated in redemption and wanted to make use of a virgin.
This time she has a capital V, which is blessed mother.
What portents and projities of graces did it not work in her?
My will is great.
It contains all goods and in operating it acts with magnanimity and if it is about doing
works and doing good for all humanity, then it puts all of its goods at stake.
Isn't that absolutely amazing?
So there you have a description of eternal love that's beyond description to me.
Jeremiah 31-3, I've loved you with an everlasting love.
It's just beyond description.
So the last paragraph is about the restoration of the human race.
I just write the restoration there.
So if we're going to compare blessed mother and Louisa, I would call blessed mother the
great virgin and Louisa the little one.
Now Jesus said, "The divine will wants to make use of another virgin, small V."
Notice there was a big V in order to centralize its will in her.
Notice it's a small H as distinct from a capital with blessed mother.
And to begin to make known that its will must be done on earth as is in heaven.
And if in redemption it wanted to come and save lost man to satisfy for his sins, which
man had no power to do, and to give him refuge and many other goods which redemption contains,
now wanting to display even more love than in redemption, which is incredible, isn't it?
I didn't think it was possible.
By making my will be done on earth as it is in heaven, my will comes to give man his
state of origin that we go back to pick up from where Adam left off.
To give man back his nobility and the purpose for which he was created.
It comes to open the current between itself and the human will.
Now there's definitely different ways you could say that in modern times.
You could say open the email account, there's communication.
Open the electric current.
Open the ladder between heaven and earth if you want to use a John 151.
The current is this conversation between God and us.
It's our particular conversation.
That's why I use the expression email initially.
I have my own one, we all have emails, we all have communication.
But each one of us has this conversation with God.
So it's to start the conversation with God.
So it's to open the current between the divine will and the human will.
So in such a way that absorbed by this divine will being dominated by it, the human will
give it life within itself and my will will reign on earth as it does in heaven.
You can say that very, very simply.
When the current opens between God and me about whose will is to rule, then there's
not really a conversation, is there?
Everyone has to give way to the other because the human will don't mix, they're like iron
and water, they don't mix.
So the human will gives way to the divine and the divine will begins to take over and
therefore the transformation of the human person and the fulfillment of the our father
in that person.
And of course, he's returned to the earth because now he has a tabernacle on earth.
And the marvelous thing is that in each one of us, he has a tabernacle and from that tabernacle
is radiating his graces out to everybody, not just the people where you live and the
country that you live, but to everybody of all times.
So April the 20th, 1923, God does his greatest works in virgin and unknown souls.
Now notice there's been a lot of emphasis on virgin.
When you look at the history of the church and you see that when either Jesus or Mary
come to communicate with us, they choose somebody who is either completely on educated, therefore
they've been untouched by human opinions, that's a virgin mind, now do you get it?
And they choose somebody who has not been violated in any way by human emotions.
So it's a virgin heart.
We're always inclined to think that it's virgin is merely to do with body.
They do like virgins that way as well because God likes something that nobody else has touched.
Is that okay?
Well, we forget the virgin mind and the virgin heart and the virgin soul.
I mean, if you look at Bernadette of Lords, she's a very good example, she had no idea
what our lady said to her, none whatsoever, she just simply repeated.
And yet she had an absolutely exalted relationship with God and her body is still smiling at
us.
You know, I read a comment from a Protestant source about Bernadette, they weren't trying
to be derogatory or anything, but they called her the perfect sleeping beauty because she's
so beautiful, you know, and she still has her smile, her little smile.
So that's the virgin thing.
He likes something that's untouched.
You see, if he has somebody with a virgin mind, he's not going to come up against other
theories of theology or other theories of God or other theories of anything.
And in Louisa, he has that because Louisa has no education, you know, unless you think
what you learn in infants or babies class is major education.
And so there's no other thinking of anybody else interfering.
And so the Lord can write on a clean slate.
If you look at that man that our lady appeared to in Guadalupe, was his name when Diego again,
uneducated, she was she had a clean slate to write on there was nothing that was going
to interfere either in his relationship with her or in what he would say to the church.
He had no personal opinion on the subject, do you know what I mean?
Or he could let her work a miracle through him.
He was not going to put his own mind in between what she wanted and what the church was to
receive.
I just want to illustrate that because you might have a narrow thinking about virgin.
I was thinking over what had been said above, Louisa said, and my poor mind was swimming
in the sea of the divine will.
I felt so drowned in it.
In many things I lacked the words, you see, you're dealing here with the virgin mind.
In others, since they are many, I'm unable to keep the order.
And it seems to me that I put them on paper disconnected.
But it seems that Jesus bears with me, it's enough that I write them.
And if I don't, he reproaches me and he says, "Mind this, these are not things that must
serve you alone.
They must serve others as well."
So I was thinking to myself if Jesus loves that this way of living in the divine will
be known, since it will be a new era which will bring about so much good as to surpass
the very good of redemption.
So what he's doing is thinking of exactly what he said.
He could have spoken to the Pope, you know, I think that's brilliant.
Who's the head of the church having the authority?
And he could immediately influence the members of the whole church by making known this celestial
doctrine.
And by bringing this great good to the human generations, I wonder if the priest said that
or do you know what I mean?
Or he could have spoken to some authoritative people.
Now a targeted of people would be the bishop and the priests.
To them it would be easier, but how can I, a poor ignorant one and unknown, make this
great good known?
Now he has told her that Blessed Mother was unknown during her lifetime.
And Jesus sighing and pressing me more tightly to himself, there's the hard love again.
He told me, "Daughter, so very dear to my supreme volition, it's my usual way to do
my greatest works."
He's told her this before, "In virgin and unknown souls," that's exactly what he said
in the last message.
And not only virgin by nature, that's in their bodies, but virgin in their affections,
heart and thought.
Is he what I was trying to say to you?
Because true virginity is a divine shadow.
So it enables the person to be drawn into God much more easily.
And only in my shadow can I fertilize, I hate the word fecundate, my greatest works.
During the times in which I came to redeem, there were also punts of sanitarities, and
I didn't go to them because my shadow was not there, and you see that at the end of
the Gospel.
Therefore I chose a virgin capital V for Blessed Mother, unknown to all, but well known
to me.
And if true virginity is my shadow, it was divine jealousy that choosing her Blessed
Mother, unknown, wanting her Blessed Mother, all for myself, kept Blessed Mother unknown
to everybody.
That was also for her protection.
But even though this celestial virgin was unknown, I made myself known by making my way
to make redemption known to all.
So he's going to talk about divine camouflage in the next section.
Because when you go into the animal or plant world, camouflage is terribly important.
The plant or the animal don't want to be destroyed by the prey that likes them.
So they put on certain camouflage that will sort of give the message, "I'm not who you
think I am."
Now loads of magnificent photographs on my computer illustration this all over the place.
All of them are screamingly funny, both for plants as well as animals pretending to be
something else.
And so they hide from their predator that way.
Okay.
The greater the work I want to do, Jesus said, "The more I covered the soul with the appearance
of ordinary things," there's the camouflage.
She looks completely ordinary.
Now since the persons you mention are known people, namely the pope and the leaders of
the church, the divine jealousy could not maintain its watch.
And the divine shadow, "Oh, how hard it is to find it, okay, want to give you, okay."
And besides, "I choose whomever I please," that exact statement is in Romans 9 from verses
14 to 18.
"I choose whom I choose."
It is established that two virgins must come to humanity's aid, one for the salvation
of man and the other for my reign on the earth.
And that's Jesus' answer to the two guys who wanted to sit on his right and on his left.
Okay.
They only wanted honor.
These women have to suffer incredibly.
The one for the salvation of man and the other for my will to reign upon the earth and to
give man his terrestrial happiness and to unite the two wills, the divine and the human,
and to make them one so that the purpose for which man was created may have its complete
fulfillment.
I myself will take care of making my way to make known what I want.
So he tells Louisa, "Your job actually is to just receive, respond, live in the divine
will and write the testimony.
Do you don't have anything else to do?
Others will take it off from there."
What I most care about is to have the first creature to whom to centralize my volition
and that my will may have life in her on earth as it is in heaven.
He says, "The most important thing is that I, my will, can operate in you exactly as
it operates in heaven."
That means the same as it operates in the saints in heaven.
The rest will come by itself, he said, "This is why I always say to you your flight in
my will because the human will contains weaknesses, passions, miseries and these are veils which
prevent one from entering into the divine volition.
Hence in volumes one to four he tells us to go into mortification, self-denial, get on
top of the passions and so on and start giving yourself all the time to the Lord otherwise
we can't move on, otherwise you can't get the wings because these things are veils that
prevent us from moving."
And of course if there are grave sins they are barricades to form between the divine
and the human will.
So there's no possibility of being in the divine will with sin and particularly grave
sin we would call that mortal sin.
And if my will on earth as it is in heaven does not reign upon the earth, this is precisely
what prevents it from doing so, in other words all these passions and miseries and sins
and so on.
Therefore to you it's given to tear these veils, to knock down these barricades that's
all the suffering and the reparation and to make of all human acts as though one single
act by the power of my will overwhelming them all and bringing them to the feet of my celestial
father as though kissed and sealed by his divine will.
So that in seeing that one creature has covered the whole human family with his will, attracted
and pleased he may let his will descend upon the earth through her, making it reign on
earth as it does in heaven, good stop there.